c'était ma femme a dû crédit un
documentaire totalement immersif réalisé
par Sébastien le Belzic alors il est
actuellement en Chine c'est le
producteur de ce documentaire qui nous
fait l'honneur de participer à Z Anthony
Dufour bonjour alors vous êtes
producteur de films on vient de le dire
journaliste et ancien correspondant en
Asie si je dis pas de bêtises vous avez
vécu 10 ans en Corée c'est ça et à Pékin
très bien ça tombe bien à vos côtés nous
avons invité Benoît pied d'alu bonjour
Chef de projet national service
numérique partagé et membre de la
Quadrature du Net une association qui
défend les libertés fondamentales dans
l'environnement numérique vous avez tous
les deux accepté l'invitation des élèves
du lycée Durzy à Villemandeur bonjour
les élèves
voilà donc nous sommes dans le Loiret
vous avez beaucoup beaucoup de questions
à poser à nos deux invités je le sais
vous avez énormément travaillé mais
juste avant juste avant que vous posiez
toutes vos questions j'aimerais d'abord
vous demander ce que vous avez pensé de
ce documentaire dites moi un petit peu
oui oui c'est quelque chose que j'ai
découvert ça a permis de découvrir une
autre façon de vivre que ici ça a permis
de découvrir comment le gouvernement
chinois espionne entre guillemets sa
population la notion d'espionnage c'est
quelque chose qui vous a marqué oui oui
je te vois réagir dis-moi oui mais ce
qui m'a plu s'étonner c'est le fait que
les les habitants ils avaient pas l'air
dérangé par ça que c'était un mode de
vie normale ok est-ce que vous avez tous
des téléphones portables oui OK je suis
pas sûr que vous vous utilisiez des
applications comme des taxis uber tout
ça mais vous mais j'imagine que dans vos
familles ça se pratique ouais ça vous
arrive et est-ce que ça vous paraît
bizarre vous de noter les gens de mettre
une étoile deux étoiles trois étoiles
dis-moi Anna bah moi ça m'avait pas
semblé dérangeant avant mais c'est vrai
que maintenant que j'ai vu le
documentaire
j'ai vu j'ai une autre perception de la
chose et bah je le prends différemment
parce que je pensais qu'avant c'était
bah pour conseiller les gens qui qui se
sentent un petit peu plus en sécurité
mais au final je me dis au final on
équipe pour pouvoir juger ce que la
personne comment elle a été avec nous
on va justement passer à vos questions
et on commence avec audiane qui est
juste là c'est une question pour Anthony
Dufour y a-t-il une législation ou des
accords à obtenir pour filmer un tel
documentaire en Chine et pouvez-vous
nous expliquer dans quelles conditions
ce tournage a-t-il pu se faire
alors bien sûr comme dans tous les pays
pour aller filmer pour aller faire du
journalisme dans un pays où on doit
obtenir un visa et nous on a un visa
donc il arrive et la société qui a
l'agence de presse qui a qui a produit
ce documentaire on a un visa depuis 2003
en Chine donc on a l'autorisation
d'avoir un bureau qui nous permet
d'avoir des journalistes en Chine c'est
le cas de l'Agence France Presse du
journal Le Monde de grandes radios de
France Télévisions ils ont aussi un
bureau à Pékin pour faire de
l'information et pour ça on doit obtenir
effectivement un
visa un gros papier avec un gros cachet
bien rouge du gouvernement chinois ça
nous a pris nous très longtemps à avoir
cette autorisation c'est encore une
question pour Monsieur Anthony Dufour
étant donné qu'Internet est très
contrôlé par le régime comment avez-vous
récupéré le reportage
alors ça c'est un secret de fabrication
on va pouvoir te le dire mais c'est vrai
que on doit utiliser des stratégies pour
pouvoir récupérer à chaque fois qu'on
qu'on fait les images en Chine alors il
y a des stratégies toutes simples on
l'envoie des disques durs on fait des
allers-retours en avion alors à l'époque
quand on a fait ce reportage c'est bien
difficile parce qu'il y avait plus
d'avion pour la Chine c'était le covid
donc on a des petits stratagèmes on
passe par des pays tiers notamment pour
pouvoir envoyer le les éléments vidéo
alors ça peut prendre parfois des jours
et des jours et des jours l'Internet
chinois il y a et contrôlé par ce qu'on
appelle la Grande Muraille numérique
c'est à dire qu'il y a très peu de
points d'entrée de points de connexion
entre la Chine et le reste du monde si
vous voulez vous connecter à la site
étranger il y a de grandes chances qui
sont interdits tout ce que vous
connaissez un Facebook Instagram tous
ces applications là sont bloquées et
quand l'appliquer et quand le le site
est autorisé en général ça met assez
longtemps à pouvoir se connecter donc on
doit chercher des stratégies pour
réussir à envoyer les gros fichiers la
manière la plus efficace possible mais
ça nous occupe ça me prend beaucoup de
temps ça
oui Younes c'est une question pour
Anthony Dufour est-ce que certaines
scènes ont dû être retirées du reportage
à cause de la censure ou pour d'autres
motifs oui alors ça c'est quelque chose
sur lequel on est toujours très prudent
moi je fais des films en Chine depuis
plus de 20 ans
et donc on a toujours un grand soin à ne
pas exposer les gens qui qui participent
à nos à nos documentaires notamment
évidemment les Chinoises ce qu'il faut
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est pour les
Chinois d'aujourd'hui n'ont pas accès à
toutes les sources d'information
auxquelles vous vous avez accès donc
est-ce qu'on a le droit de dire quelque
chose ou est-ce qu'on a pas le droit de
le dire la règle elle est un petit peu
floue c'est pas si simple ceux qui sont
devenus des dissidents disent toujours à
peu près la même histoire ils sont
devenus dissidence on s'en rende compte
ils ont raconté une histoire ils ont dit
quelque chose et puis bah il pensait
qu'ils le faisaient de manière légitime
voir de manière vertueuse et puis boum
il se trouve que c'est interdit et donc
ils sont devenus distillerie donc nous
on fait très attention et en général oui
on coupe les scènes ou quand les gens
disent des choses qui nous sont pas
appropriées parce que même sans pas
compte parfois qu'ils franchissent des
limites qui pourraient leur valoir des
problèmes et on fait également très
attention aux gens qui travaillent avec
nous c'est à dire que forcément vous
avez des équipes chinoises il y a des
caméraman il y a des preneurs de son
tous ces gens là pourraient aussi se
retrouver impliqués dans des problèmes
politiques ou dans la répression à leur
égard et donc on fait très attention à
les protéger à pas les nommer ou
simplement à les exclure quand on sait
que ça va être un peu sensible et que ça
va être un peu compliqué pour eux et
vous Benoît vous l'avez vu ce
documentaire qu'est-ce que vous en avez
pensé
alors c'est un très très beau panorama
en effet de ce qui se passe là-bas c'est
effectivement très intéressant de voir
de l'intérieur alors on avait déjà un
savant d'information sur comment ça se
passait on a vu des conférences déjà
depuis plusieurs années sur le Crédit
Social chinois comment ça se développait
dans la société chinoise là-bas voir ça
à travers les yeux de d'une chinoise en
l'occurrence qui l'analyse qui explique
comment elle le vit au quotidien ça
change un peu le point de vue de ce
qu'on a l'habitude de voir c'est à dire
de nos yeux européens qui jugeons depuis
la France en l'occurrence sur ce qui se
passe là-bas ça permet de changer de
regard et donc de voir un peu comment
eux le sentent sur place et ça m'a
semblé effectivement un point de vue
très intéressant pour un documentaire en
quoi c'était très intéressant parce que
ça ça bousculé un peu vos a priori
peut-être alors pas forcément parce que
j'ai travaillé dans un certain nombre
d'entreprises dans lesquelles on avait
parlé des jeunes Chinois qui venaient
travailler chez nous et qui nous
expliquait que finalement le fait que
l'Internet soit contrôler la base
c'était très bien ça leur permettait
d'éviter de voir des choses qui ne
devaient pas voir alors nous on était un
peu surpris de notre point de vue mais
c'est vrai que finalement en regardant
ce documentaire moi j'ai pas été tant
étonné de ce point de vue finalement
d'acceptabilité de ce contrôle
généralisé parce que j'avais déjà été en
contact avec un certain nombre de
citoyens chinois qui eux acceptaient
déjà il y a une quinzaine d'années ce
genre de ce genre de contrôle en
particulier de du contenu de l'Internet
puisque je rappelle que il y a même des
pages de Wikipédia qui sont interdites
d'accès
en l'occurrence et donc c'était c'était
un peu ça la
le gros avantage de ce documentaire par
rapport à juste des analyses externes de
ce qui s'y passe Lilou Lilou qui est
juste ici c'est une question encore pour
Benoît pied d'alu que pensez-vous de ce
mode de vie
de ces modes de vie à la chinoise
j'imagine c'est ça que tu veux dire
alors nous on a la coloration du net on
considère que il faut qu'on lutte contre
le déploiement de ce type de technologie
contre la surveillance permanente en
effet de la population parce que ça
modifierait nos comportements parce que
ça apporte aussi
un outil extrêmement puissant à l'état
c'est à dire que des technologies type
reconnaissance faciale dans les rues
apporterait énormément d'informations à
l'état qui pour nous ne sont pas du
ressort de l'état car il n'y a pas de
raison aujourd'hui pour que l'État
accumule tant d'informations sur ces
concitoyens l'État c'est nous finalement
l'état ce sont des gens que nous avons
mis en position de gérer la vie de la
cité c'est ça la démocratie c'est gérer
la République c'est c'est gérer la vie
de la cité
et c'est nous qui les mettons à cette
position là il n'y a pas de raison que
ces gens accumulent des informations sur
nos opinions politiques sur le fait
qu'on soit syndiqué ou pas sur le fait
qu'on soit opposé ou pas au gouvernement
parce que c'est aussi ce qui a été fait
par exemple en Inde en Inde on a dit ah
oui ça pourrait être effectivement
intéressant de mettre en place ce type
de surveillance en Inde c'était pour
retrouver les enfants perdus c'est un
très gros problème les enfants qui sont
perdus il faut les retrouver donc le
gouvernement a dit on va mettre en place
de la reconnaissance faciale comme ça on
va retrouver les enfants quelques mois
après l'installation du système
manifestation dans les rues comme le
gouvernement et hop on a listé tous les
gens qui étaient opposés au gouvernement
voilà ce genre de système quand vous les
mettez en place en fait vous savez pas à
quoi ils vont être utilisés donner de la
force donner de la puissance comme ça de
contrôle d'une population à un état
finalement c'est ne pas enfin c'est les
laisser faire ce qu'ils veulent avec
l'information des choses que vous
n'aurez pas imaginé au moment où ça a
été mis en place c'était pour régler un
problème et finalement ça va être un
outil d'oppression contre certaines
populations on va essayer de contacter
le réalisateur il est en Chine en ce
moment et on va essayer de on va essayer
de le joindre il environ 21h chez lui on
va aller voir si on peut le si on peut
l'appeler alors on va se connecter deux
petites secondes
bonjour tous les élèves sont là vous les
voyez
vous nous entendez bien
merci merci beaucoup alors vous êtes en
Chine vous êtes où exactement là je suis
dans une province du sud de la Chine je
suis pas à Pékin cette semaine très bien
voilà donc vous le savez les élèves du
lycée durzi ont vu votre documentaire
ils ont plein de questions à vous poser
et on va commencer avec toi Léa on
t'écoute quels étaient vos motivations
pour réaliser ce documentaire nos
motivations déjà on avait envie de
témoigner de notre vie quotidienne avec
avec ma femme Lulu on avait envie de
raconter comment les choses se passaient
ici en Chine au quotidien parce que
c'est vrai que on a un peu du mal à
comprendre
quel est l'impact de ces nouvelles
technologies de cette surveillance et de
fait de vivre dans un pays quand même
très très surveillé on va dire comme la
Chine et donc un petit peu au fil du
temps on a pu faire évoluer ce
documentaire et raconter notre vie
quotidienne par ce biais de la
surveillance et des nouvelles
technologies c'est ça avez-vous été
témoin d'acte de répression envers des
citoyens dont le nombre de points a été
faible moi personnellement non il faut
savoir que en fait les choses ne se font
pas
face à vous parce que tout l'intérêt de
cette de cette surveillance électronique
c'est que elle se fait de façon
insidieuse et une personne par exemple
qui se retrouve sur une liste noire pour
telle ou telle raison et donc il pourra
pas voyager prendre le train ou l'avion
elle le sait pas forcément à l'avance
quoi c'est au moment où elle va acheter
son billet où elle souhaite se déplacer
et bien que elles se retrouvent bloquées
et là elles se rencontrent c'est ce que
les gens nous disent en tout cas
qu'effectivement elles sont sur une une
sorte de liste no donc c'est une un
système de surveillance qui est beaucoup
plus insidieux beaucoup plus discret
c'est vrai que jusque là les policiers
venaient frapper directement à votre
porte ou vous convoquer au commissariat
pour vous interroger dorénavant il
suffit tout simplement de vous de vous
bloquer sur Internet ou de vous envoyer
des messages pour pour vous empêcher de
faire ce que vous voulez faire donc on
n'a pas été témoin direct d'une personne
qui a essayé de prendre le train et qui
s'est retrouvé bloqué mais c'est en
général comme ça comme ça que ça se
passe les gens le découvrent à ce moment
là mais c'est vrai que là récemment
encore j'ai
eu TGV je me suis rendu compte qu'il y
avait parfois des messages effectivement
qui étaient diffusés sur les
haut-parleurs qui disait attention si
vous vous comportez mal votre crédit
social pourra être impacté pourra être
impacté donc vous pourrez plus prendre
le train donc c'est vrai que c'est des
petites choses qui sont qui se
retrouvent comme ça dans la vie
quotidienne on n'a pas été jusqu'à
effectivement violer la loi ou faire des
choses répréhensibles pour voir dans
quelle mesure on allait se retrouver
bloquer mais mais d'autres personnes en
ont fait la mer expérience on va dire
Mathilde dans ce reportages on remarque
que les citoyens sont dépendants d'un
système de points savez-vous à partir de
quel âge ils y sont soumis ils y sont
soumis à partir du moment où
ils sont la nécessité d'utiliser
toutes ces applications Internet partir
je sais pas à partir de quel âge ils ont
un téléphone un téléphone portable et
une application par lequel il se
comporte de façon de façon autonome mais
dans la mesure où ils vont pas par
exemple scanner leur faire enregistrer
leur carte d'identité pour prendre pour
prendre le train ou se déplacer ou
accéder au porte-monnaie virtuel vous
avez vu qu'on pouvait payer simplement
en scannant son visage et bien ils ne
sont pas soumis à cette à ce contrôle là
donc je dirais jusqu'à leur majorité ils
sont en fait dépendants de leurs parents
donc à partir de 18 ans en Chine là ils
sont totalement autonomes et donc
responsable pénalement et aussi donc ils
ont accès à cette à cette surveillance à
cette surveillance électronique à cette
sorte de de crédit à points en fait dans
leur dans leur vie quotidienne
Axel est-ce que vous savez si la Chine
envisage d'appliquer ce système de
points au mineur pour les mineurs
questions mais ce qu'on essayait de
montrer aussi c'est que cette
surveillance électronique que ce soit
par le biais d'un de points ou crédit
social mais également par le biais de la
vidéo surveillance ou par le biais
d'intelligence artificielle elle se
répand partout dans la société chinoise
ça vient ça va bien bien plus loin que
ce système de crédit social et là les
mineurs les jeunes ils sont directement
soumis on a l'exemple en Chine par
exemple de classe d'élèves donc dans les
écoles qui sont surveillés par des
caméras reliées à des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle et donc ils
peuvent surveiller si vous êtes bien
attentif si vous posez les bonnes
questions si vous avez tendance à vous
assouplir pendant les cours donc cette
surveillance elle est partout elle peut
aussi bien être dans les salles de
classe que dans les transports que dans
la rue et bien merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup Sébastien lebelzig avoir
répondu aux questions des élèves bravo
pour votre pour votre film et puis nous
on va on va continuer les échanges ici à
Villemandeur merci encore au revoir
merci beaucoup au revoir juste pour pour
réagir à ce que vous venez d'entendre
qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit
ok donc en Chine on peut filmer des
classes et surveiller si les élèves
suivent
Nantes oui dis-moi c'est très intrusif
parce que même enfin on peut rien faire
sans que on soit sûr que ce sera vu par
quelqu'un d'autre qui va nous contrôler
on peut pas faire de blagues peut-être
un peu idiotes parfois on est sûr que il
y aura forcément des conséquences donc
faut faire attention à tout c'est pas
trop une vie mais si ça vous permet
d'avoir une meilleure note vous acceptez
ou pas dis-moi Jean David malgré tout
c'est qu'il y a un souci ne serait-ce
qu'au niveau de la liberté c'est à dire
que là on en est un niveau de
surveillance qui est quand même
extrêmement c'est à dire que non on n'a
pas juste un professeur qui va essayer
de guider les élèves non on a des
caméras on va essayer de dire aux élèves
faites attention à chaque mouvement vous
allez être tout le temps surveiller en
fait c'est un avant-goût un petit peu de
la société chinoise et effectivement ça
peut commencer à poser un problème si je
suis chef d'établissement et je vous dis
demain j'installe des caméras de
surveillance si vous l'acceptez
j'installe des caméras de surveillance
dans la classe tous ceux qui disent oui
ont 15 minimum
de surveiller le comportement des élèves
c'est pas lié à ça d'avoir une bonne
note mais si moi si moi je te maintiens
si moi je signe je dis voilà je mets 15
à tout le monde à partir du moment où je
mets des caméras de surveillance dans la
classe et puis après ben en fonction de
votre comportement je mettrai un petit
peu plus ou vous signez tous vous dites
oui ok vas-y dis-moi non parce que en
soit oui on voudrait tout savoir 15 de
moyenne c'est enfin ce serait bon pour
notre futur pour tout mais ok il y a la
moyenne mais il y a aussi notre
comportement
on veut aussi être libre faire ce qu'on
veut
tout en on peut avoir des bonnes notes
mais aussi avoir notre comportement tel
qu'on veut c'est intéressant oui dis-moi
finalement on n'est pas naturel on n'est
pas nous-mêmes donc c'est une forme
d'hypocrisie aussi cette présentation
qui a été faite de ce qu'il pouvait se
passer en classe c'est à dire des
caméras de bio surveillance qui peuvent
analyser le comportement des élèves
savoir s'ils sont attentifs
si un moment il dérive un peu ou autre
c'est des choses qu'on a vu il y a pas
si longtemps que ça en Europe le
règlement général à la protection des
données je sais pas si vous en avez
entendu parler le rgpd qui est entré en
vigueur en Europe en 2018 en mai 2018
la première amande qui a été qui a été
faite au nom du rgpd a été faite auprès
d'une école qui avait mis en place des
caméras de de contrôle de système
biométrique qui mesure si vous êtes
attentif si vous regardez devant vous
etc etc donc des choses très très
poussées de contrôle de l'attention des
élèves dans un pays nordique de l'Europe
voilà donc en fait cette idée de
contrôler le comportement des élèves en
cours en fait elle existe déjà la seule
chose qui peut aujourd'hui l'arrêter au
niveau européen c'est la législation et
la protection des données et la
protection des libertés donc si on
attend juste que les responsables
pédagogique des directeurs
d'établissements se disent bah non en
fait ça ne sert à rien ils vont
effectivement ne pas être naturels ou
autre bah en fait ça marche pas les
mêmes des responsables pédagogiques se
disent que ça peut être une bonne idée
de contrôler les élèves avec la
technologie est-ce que vous pensez que
la vie privée elle a disparu en Chine
pense que la vie privée totalement
disparue
c'est pas comme si il choisissait ce
qu'il voulait faire ou de quoi il
voulait parler ils sont obligés
maintenant de dire qu'ils sont d'accord
avec le gouvernement et que tout ce
qu'ils font c'est bien tu voulais
rajouter quelque chose c'est
comme et le truc c'est qu'il leur prend
pas confiance
Zoé je pense qu'ils n'ont aucune vie
privée aujourd'hui donc plus aucune vie
parce que ils sont tout en filmés dans
le reportage il disait qu'il y avait une
caméra pour deux habitants et comme on
est tout le temps filmé enfin ils sont
tout le temps filmés ils savent avec qui
ils sont ceux qui font du coup ils ont
aucune vie en fait
on va se filmer comme ça pendant un an
tu es d'accord
mais j'ai pas de bruit
on a pas de vie privée de toute façon
[Musique]
en Chine on compte au moins une caméra
de surveillance pour deux habitants
[Musique]
des yeux électroniques qui nous
regardent en permanence
[Musique]
le contrôle mis en place à Pékin cette
situation est-elle est-elle en place
dans tout le pays et pensez-vous que ce
genre de surveillance est voué à ces
temps dans le monde entier évidemment ce
qui fait la différence entre la Chine et
le reste du monde c'est qu'en Chine vous
créez des fichiers vous créez des
données à chaque fois que vous faites un
acte vous allez dans la rue vous êtes
filmé vous achetez une banane au
supermarché on sait que vous avez acheté
une banane et payer avec alipé
l'application sur votre téléphone
portable on connaît votre compte en
banque on connaît votre assurance on
connaît enfin vous avez des fichiers
partout mais ça finalement c'est la même
chose en France on a des fichiers
partout dans tout quand vous avez aussi
une carte bancaire vous avez aussi un
téléphone vous avez aussi une compagnie
d'assurance tous ces éléments-là font
des fichiers avec grande différence avec
la Chine c'est qu'en Chine l'état croise
tous ces fichiers et capable de dresser
un portrait à l'aide en comparant et en
mixant toutes ces données et donc on est
en capable de savoir qu'elle lit vous
avez emprunté à la bibliothèque et quel
film vous avez regardé ce soir sur
Netflix il y a pas Netflix donc sur
autre chose mais en tous les cas c'est
ça qui est le grand c'est le fait de
croiser de croiser l'ensemble des choses
et puis sur un plan territorial oui la
Chine s'étend étant son influence on va
ce qui s'est passé à Hong Kong il y a
pas si longtemps vous avez vu la
jeunesse qui s'est révolté la révolution
des parapluies et puis toute cette
jeunesse qui est sorti dans la rue
justement pour dire on veut pas de ce
système eux ils ont été ils ont été à
l'école dans un système qui était proche
d'une autre un système occidental
hérité de la tradition anglaise ou
justement la liberté faisait
complètement partie du modèle de Hong
Kong on leur a dit bah ça y est la Chine
prend le pouvoir et donc on va appliquer
petit à petit le modèle chinois il y a
une énorme révolte c'est aussi tout ce
qui se passe autour de Taïwan vous savez
c'est cette île qui est au large de de
l'acide et que la Chine souhaite
contrôler alors qu'aujourd'hui elle vit
de manière différentielle avec une
élection avec un président avec une
démocratie tous ces tous ces enjeux là
sont évidemment très forts et Pékin oui
souhaite étendre les mêmes méthodes dans
tous les territoires qui contrôlent de
manière plus ou moins directe marylon
à pied cette technologie pourrait-elle
s'étendre dans le monde
alors oui en effet aujourd'hui la
tendance est de déployer ce type de
technologie un peu partout
on a même sans attendre le monde entier
on a déjà on peut les voir arriver dans
nos contrées en France la vidéo
surveillance automatisée un peu la
première étape la première pierre qui
est mis en place par le par l'État ça
peut être le gouvernement de manière
générale sur le territoire mais aussi
chaque petite mairie peut décider de
mettre en place des systèmes de
vidéosurveillance qu'on appelle
automatiser ou algorithmique parce qu'en
fait derrière chaque flux vidéo vous
mettez un ordinateur et vous détectez
des événements ça c'est vraiment la
première étape et ça aujourd'hui on les
voit apparaître on les voit se déployer
dans nos villes donc nous on a fait un
peu l'analyse avec la collaborateur du
net on a plein d'entreprises en France
sur le territoire qui déploie enfin qui
crée ce type de technologie et qui
veulent les vendre donc ils font
beaucoup de lobbies ils vont voir les
personnes qui sont en charge des
décisions d'achat de sécurité et autres
en disant ben nous on a des supers
technologies regardez en plus on est on
est à côté on est sur le territoire
français donc chez nous vous allez voir
vous allez vous allez améliorer votre
sécurité et puis on a aussi des
entreprises chinoises les entreprises
qui déploient les systèmes que vous
voyez dans ce documentaire sont en
France et proposent aux mairies
françaises je pense par exemple la
mairie de Valenciennes la société Huawei
qui est le plus grand fabricant de ces
matériels de surveillance aussi de
téléphone c'est la plus
une des immenses sociétés de
électronique chinoise a proposé à des
villes françaises de faire des
expérimentations c'est à dire de venir
déployer son système pour montrer
regardez vous avez vu ce qu'on s'est
fait en Chine c'est super on peut le
faire chez vous aussi quand vous êtes
maire d'une ville et vous avez besoin
d'un système de surveillance et que vous
voyez ce documentaire alors évidemment
nous avec nos valeurs on est choqué on
dit c'est pas possible mais quand vous
cherchez un système efficace et que vous
voyez ce genre de documentaire peut-être
quelque chose à faire et finalement
c'est la réflexion que font aujourd'hui
certains élus en l'occurrence Huawei a
installé quasiment gratuitement sa son
dispositif à Valenciennes pour faire une
démonstration et pour montrer que c'est
possible et qu'on arrive à le faire donc
toutes ces technologies que vous voyez
elles existent elles sont utilisées en
France aujourd'hui on a zéro preuve que
ce genre nouvelles technologies améliore
la sécurité d'une casconque manière mais
oui on voit monter en puissance cette
petite musique de la surveillance
automatisée algorithmique dans l'espace
public et le pire du pire que nous on
considère être extrêmement dangereux
c'est la reconnaissance biométrique
c'est à dire de pouvoir déterminer un
pas seulement la reconnaissance faciale
il y a pas besoin de scanner le visage
forcément on sait vous reconnaître rien
qu'à votre démarche la manière dont vous
marchez c'est une reconnaissance
biométrique c'est-à-dire que vous n'êtes
pas capable ça c'est très très difficile
d'aller faire une démarche qui soit
différente en fait vous avez toujours la
même alors vous vous êtes encore
peut-être en train de grandir donc vous
avez peut-être évolué encore mais une
fois que vous avez votre démarche
d'adulte en fait on va vous reconnaître
rien quand vous voyez en marché voilà
donc la reconnaissance biométrique c'est
vraiment très large et où on a on a
combattu l'installation de portique de
reconnaissance faciale à l'entrée de
lycée à Nice et Marseille donc l'idée
c'est vous avez plus personne qui vous
accueille à l'entrée de votre lycée il
n'y a pas besoin parce que bon ça coûte
cher d'avoir de payer des gens pour
faire ça donc on met des portiques
vous voyez un peu quand on fait rentrer
des vaches dans un dans un pré elle
passe par un parti bah là c'est la même
chose vous passez par là et puis vous
avez une caméra qui vous regarde et qui
vous dit oui vous avez le droit de venir
au lycée aujourd'hui ou non vous avez
pas du lycée vous avez pas le droit de
rentrer aujourd'hui bah en fait c'est
vous qui êtes les cobayes parce que
c'est vous qui servez de matière
première à l'enrichissement à
l'entraînement de ce type de technologie
et ça c'est quand même un peu c'est
quelque chose qui est pas vraiment
débattu
vous accepteriez vous les portiques à
l'entrée du lycée Jean David
les élèves et les intrus donc à la fois
ça pourrait être une bonne idée sauf que
effectivement sauf si on nous scanne
tous les jours dès le matin avec une
mine voilà un petit peu récraque
forcément ça va pas être tout le temps
une bonne idée tu as commencé par ça
pourrait être une bonne idée
parce qu'en fait ça peut éviter aussi
l'intrusion finalement c'est à dire que
il faut il faut il faut bien
identifier les élèves et les dissocier
par exemple de quelqu'un qui va essayer
de s'introduire pour
la vie scolaire etc non
en effet
alors pour information c'était
effectivement c'était ce qui avait été
mis en avant c'est-à-dire lutter contre
la l'intrusion de personnes extérieures
il y a eu une réunion avec le chef
d'établissement avec différentes
personnes les parents d'élèves aussi et
la question a été posée à cette occasion
là de savoir mais finalement est-ce
qu'il y a beaucoup d'intrusions dans ce
lycée et en fait il y a pas d'intrusion
il y a jamais eu vraiment d'intrusion
dans le lycée donc on lutte par la
technologie contre des problèmes qui
n'existent pas en effet ça baisse un
petit peu l'utilité du coup
seriez-vous prêt à vivre dans un pays
avec un système de contrôle similaire
non
non puisque je me bats beaucoup et je
passe beaucoup de temps à me battre
contre ce type de système donc en effet
aujourd'hui on essaye de faire un
maximum pour que ça n'arrive pas ici
pour que même l'idée que ça puisse
arriver dans un en Europe même de
manière générale au niveau européen net
viennent pas et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
que on essaye même pas de le faire au
niveau français mais on essaye de le
faire au niveau européen pour que
l'idéologie autour du nota de la
notation des citoyens des citoyens des
citoyens de la surveillance généralisée
par les caméras et autres n'adviennent
pas en Europe
tant David qui lève bien la main alors
moi ce serait une question pour vous
monsieur Benoît piedalus c'est
sommes-nous finalement plus apte à juger
la censure et la surveillance en Chine
alors qu'elle est aussi présente en
France finalement ça va être compliqué
d'expliquer à la Chine que il faut
arrêter de surveiller sa population
alors que nous on monte petit à petit le
niveau de la surveillance au niveau des
outils de contrôle de la population en
particulier sur les JO 2024 on va
installer ces outils et potentiellement
de manière très pérenne avec ce projet
de loi relatif justement
aux Jeux olympiques de 2024 est-ce que
ça est-ce que c'est un peu le début de
la fin pour vous
c'est très risqué ça fait très longtemps
qu'on essaye de pousser au niveau
européen d'interdire totalement par
exemple la reconnaissance faciale la
reconnaissance biométrique pour garantir
que ça n'arrivera pas sur le territoire
typiquement ce texte il a été voté ce
texte a été voté tout à fait pour nous
c'est un premier pas dans la porte
extrêmement dangereux que que cette
possibilité donnée au gouvernement de
maître de des ordinateurs des riders
toutes les caméras de vidéosurveillance
de région entière et en effet le risque
c'est que il passe à l'étape supérieure
ils disent en fait maintenant qu'on a
tout ça qu'on a les ordinateurs
les outils qui sont mis en place nous on
les analysés on a les modes d'emploi on
a l'ensemble des options
et dans les options il y a juste une
case à cocher pour ajouter la
reconnaissance faciale tous ces outils
sont déjà complets et sont capables de
reconnaître la population et de dire si
vous personnellement vous êtes allé dans
telle rue à tel moment si vous avez
rencontré telle personne que vous êtes
rentré dans tel bâtiment qui peut par
exemple être un parti politique un
syndicat et autres et donc de dire à
cette personne tac automatiquement
l'ordinateur va pouvoir dire bah vous
faites partie de ce syndicat vous allez
voir des syndicats c'est ça vous ça
augmente votre note etc tous ces outils
sont déjà disponibles il suffit de pas
grand chose pour passer à l'étape
supérieure et ce qu'on considère en
effet c'est que c'est un effet cliquet
ce qu'on appelle l'effet cliquet c'est
qu'une fois qu'on est monté
d'une étape et ben on ne redescendra pas
et en effet c'est un gros risque qui a
été mis en place par le gouvernement
une surveillance par caméra nécessite
beaucoup d'argent est-ce que ce système
est le même dans tous les quartiers où
est-ce qu'il varie selon les catégories
sociales alors c'est un système qui est
mis en place par les gouvernements les
gouvernements locaux les provinces les
municipalités la Chine est finalement un
pays assez décentralisé avec beaucoup de
pouvoir dans les provinces c'est
beaucoup de donc finalement c'est une
espèce de course à l'échalote ou chaque
province doit montrer qu'elle a mieux
fait que l'autre et chaque municipalité
a montré qu'il a qu'il a mieux fait que
l'autre pour avoir des points dans le
cadre du système politique chinois donc
pour être un bon élève il faut avoir
déployé système être capable de le faire
donc il y a beaucoup d'argent public
mais aussi beaucoup moins privés parce
que dans un immeuble le le responsable
de l'immeuble ou le le syndic comme on
dirait en France va mettre des immeubles
pour protéger vous avez vu que même dans
l'ascenseur de chez Lulu et Sébastien il
y a une caméra donc on sait qui monte et
qui prend l'ascenseur qui descend toutes
ces caméras là sont reliées ou reliables
avec le système central donc vous avez à
la fois les moyens privés et les moyens
publics qui peuvent être centralisés et
qui peuvent être tous contrôlés par par
la puissance de l'État donc c'est une
les moyens dans ces cas-là sont infinis
puisque finalement on participe tous
chacun à l'effort de surveillance ce
qu'on est vraiment
quand quelqu'un une organisation
collecte des données oui dis-moi non
[Musique]
moi je pense que non parce que même si
c'est intelligent ça va regarder les
faits et gestes un peu suspects
on n'est pas vraiment sûr que ce soit
suspect ça peut être juste de la
discrimination
ou alors ça se trouve que la personne
qui est mal intentionnée elle est très
bien préparée elle va rien faire de
suspect et on aura vu que ce sera
suspect que après une fois que ce sera
passé donc au final ça sert pas à grand
chose effectivement la question de
savoir qu'est-ce qui est suspect et
comment est-ce qu'on définit un geste
suspect un comportement sucré parce que
c'est ça qui est présenté c'est une
vraie question politique c'est qui
décide de ce qui est suspect on avait à
Saint-Étienne par exemple la volonté
d'installer des micros ou quand je dis
on c'est l'Amérique Saint-Étienne
l'installer la volonté des micro dans
les rues pour capter des sons suspects
alors ils sont suspects c'était alors
les 6 circulaires les bruits de verre
les cris vous imaginez à la sortie de
l'école l'écrit qu'est-ce que ça allait
déclencher mais aussi les bombes de
peinture donc on voit bien un peu ce qui
est ce qui est visé par ce genre de
d'outils c'est ce qui a été défini par
Monsieur le Maire Monsieur le Maire a
dit moi j'en ai marre de voir des tags
sur mes murs et donc je vais détecter le
bruit des bombes de peinture voilà et
donc c'est la décision de ce qui est un
comportement suspect cette éminemment
politique et voilà c'est la fin de
l'émission merci merci infiniment à nos
deux invités d'avoir répondu à toutes
vos questions bravo vous pouvez vous
applaudir bravo les élèves vous avez
posé des supers questions vous avez été
très bien préparé par vos deux
professeurs qu'on peut applaudir
également bravo bravo à vous et puis
nous on se retrouve très vite avec une
nouvelle classe et un nouveau
documentaire car il n'y a pas d'âge pour
questionner le monde et ces images allez
salut
[Musique]
très bien